a trip to see the wreckage of the RMS
Titanic claimed the lives of all five
passengers on board the Titan deep sea
submersible and now Titanic director
James Cameron has weighed in on the
tragedy the five members aboard the
Titan which went missing on Sunday June
18th while enroute to the wreck of the
Titanic are now presumed dead following
a catastrophic implosion speaking to ABC
News James Cameron drew a sharp parallel
between The Disappearance of the Titan
and the historic tragedy of the boat it
was meant to explore since it was said
to be Unsinkable the sinking of the RMS
Titanic has become a parable for a
situation in which flouted safety
measures and unfounded arrogance led to
a Calamity that could otherwise have
been prevented I'm I'm struck by the
similarity of the Titanic disaster
itself Cameron is no stranger to deep
sea exploration of course nor to
exploring the RMS Titanic for his 1997
epic Cameron took cameras beneath the
waves to capture images of the sunken
wreck to do so he used submersibles not
unlike the Titan and in 2012 he
descended six miles under the waves to
explore the Mariana Trench estimated to
be the deepest area of Earth's oceans
using a submersible of his own design as
an expert on the subject Cameron quickly
became concerned with the Titan
situation I immediately got on my
network because it's you know a very
small community in the Deep submergence
group in his interview with CNN Cameron
claimed that on Monday morning the day
after the Titan launched he immediately
concluded that the submersible must have
imploded the only scenario that I could
come up with in my mind that could
account for that was it was an implosion
indeed Cameron's worst fears soon came
to life we know now that the United
States Navy heard a sound similar to an
implosion on Sunday mere hours after the
sub had descended a Navy official
confirmed that an acoustic data analysis
was conducted that detected an anomaly
consistent with an implosion in the area
in which the Titan was operating given
Cameron's relevant experience it's
perhaps unsurprising that he had some
harsh words regarding the now highly
publicized lapses of judgment that
doomed the Titan deep submergence diving
is a mature art Cameron continued by
asserting that the Titan expedition was
widely considered to be unsafe before
its Voyage down many people in the
community were very concerned about this
sub indeed reports since Sunday have
indicated a number of red flags
irregularities and safety concerns were
known to Ocean Gate Expeditions the
Titans operator prior to its final
voyage several prior issues cropped up
with these small exploratory vessel
including a battery issue and a rebuilt
hole one trip was even called off when
an Ocean Gate submersible lost contact
with its Mothership after dropping only
37 Feet beneath the surface